hey youtubers is Charlie so a bunch of
you requested a video on ego the Living
Planet so I'm going to explain his
comic-book backstory in what's going on
ego the Living Planet is actually a
really fascinating character who's
involved in a lot of Thor comics a lot
of his backstory is tied up in the Thor
comics so what a coincidence that
there's also a bunch of source stuff
happening later this year but I don't
think the James Gunn intended that
because he's just a very big space based
creature and he wanted to tell this
really interesting backstory about
family in a big part of egos back story
in the comics especially the more recent
comics is in searching for others like
him so that he can make a family for
himself there is a new round as a Marvel
giveaway going on right now I'm giving
away those Hasbro action figures that
they're releasing for spider-man
homecoming all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video but even though he's going
to be a big movie character there have
been a couple TV versions of ego in the
past if you don't remember there was a
Fantastic Four cartoon he was featured
on that he was also featured on the
Silver Surfer TV series then later on
the Super Hero Squad show and more
recently on Hulk and the agents of smash
which is probably the best TV version so
far he's actually voiced by Kevin
Michael Richardson who is like the best
person for voicing a Living Planet
me what does that planet kind of look
like dude
[Music]
living
why is it
perfect English does anybody else to get
weird you got two choices a you get us
back to earth and leave our galaxy
forever or B we slam-dunk you into the
Sun what'll it be
ego submit that's a little bit sillier
take on the character just like the
animated cartoons are it's the same with
the animated guardians of the galaxy
cartoon but if you remember the last
Guardians trailer we've actually seen
ego before he shows up in Planet four we
just haven't seen Kurt Russell yet
[Music]
what's that he says welcome to the
frickin guardians of the galaxy holy he
didn't use fricken
look out so this is probably what he
looks like when he's in Planet form and
this looks like it might be the surface
of his planet just because he can change
its shape and look it look really lush
just to make it more appealing for
people sort of like a Venus flytrap just
a lure people in so that he can devour
them so there are all kinds of questions
about the logic of how ego can make
himself a human body in how he was able
to procreate with star Laura's mother in
how Chris Pratt is able to walk around
what does that mean so during the first
Guardians movie when Nova prime says
your DNA is something ancient something
that they don't totally understand like
she couldn't quite put a name on it the
reason for that in the comics is because
the place that egos a living planet was
born is called the black galaxy is this
really weird place of space that doesn't
exist anymore it was actually eaten by a
celestial in the comics a long time ago
but within that galaxy it's sort of like
this weird biosphere of life so ego
himself the planet slowly evolved over
time gained sentience and then gained
his powers so the funny part is is a lot
of you are asking why is he called ego
the Living Planet why is that his name
because he has a big ego that's just a
you know funny wink that Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby had when they were creating
him so he was really created as a big
Thor villain like a planet-sized villain
the Thor was hired to try and get rid of
by another space race so Thor's able to
defeat him in the terms of their
agreement the terms of the defeat or
that he can never leave the black galaxy
so he's stuck in his home galaxy but
then later in the comics Galactus comes
along in Thor winds up helping him out
so ego isn't always an antagonist
sometimes he's just looking for family
sometimes he goes mad and starts to eat
other planets Galactus style so he
flip-flops back and forth a lot in the
only way that he has to get around like
he actually can move himself around when
he's in Planet form but it's only
because Galactus attached a world engine
to his South Pole so you can see that
because he's such a big character most
of the times he's shown up in the comics
it's been with a very huge cosmic
stories with characters like the
Beyonder characters like the High
Evolutionary
door khalaqtu s' to Celestials powers
and abilities though he has a number of
crazy abilities in addition to being
able to create a human form for himself
he can also manifest tentacles he can
also change the shape of his surface
like his face doesn't always look like
this he's just a normal planet he can
just make a face for himself when he
wants to speak with other people so on
top of all that because he's a living
planet a lot of like his internal organs
look like a human's internal organs even
though it's like on a planetary scale
when he's trying to consume other beings
he can manifest antibodies that help him
digest so you have to imagine this is
all happening on a planetary scale so it
looks really crazy no idea how they're
going to deal with this in the movie
because it seems like Kurt Russell is
going to be the biggest part of this so
it'll be human form ego so I cannot wait
to see how they explain it's going to be
super trippy and weird and they always
change stuff from the comics far below
its surface he has this weird brain
because he's so evolved he does have
some psionic abilities so there's been
times when he's been able to read Thor's
mind if you saw the video I did about
groots origin story and how because the
guardians of the galaxy movies have
caused a resurgence in the guardians
comics they've changed his backstory a
little bit so that it's now more movie
centric they've also changed ego the
Living Planet backstory a little bit
just making a little more interesting
and complicated so what ego learns is
that he was actually one of two things
created by the stranger just as a random
science experiment which is kind of
heartbreaking but he has a brother
called alter ego which was captured by
the collector some sort of an antagonist
for ego the collector collects unique
things
what is more unique than a living planet
so ego tries to free his brother but
learns the collectors running a social
experiment of his own trying to see what
will breed a stronger will captivity or
freedom so he's trying to pit ego
against alter ego trying to see who will
win ego wins the battle but before he
can kill his brother Thor helps out
intervenes in the remanence of alter ego
sort of formed to become a moon
surrounding ego and they fly off to
become a family together so it's sort of
a happy ending for him
as with any ridiculous
character like a giant living planet
there been a lot of crazy stories so if
you want to read some really cool ego to
living planet stories there's a story
where he becomes the home of the new
Nova Corps I know everybody wants to see
Richard Ryder Nova in the guardians of
the galaxy movies no ideas that'll ever
happen but during Nova number 20 he
actually becomes home to the Vantage our
world mine and they pilot him around as
the home of the new Nova Corps there was
a Kurt Busic story where he himself
became the earth he was planted by the
Kree Empire in the center of the earth
and slowly grew to take over the earth
that was called maximum security one
through three then there's the story
about how he has to fight his brother
the alter-ego that's astonishing Thor
number one through five and then there's
the story about how he has to fight
Galactus that's a bit of a deep cut is
1966 Thor number 160 that was sort of
Thor's second encounter with Eko the
first time was when he forced him to
stay in the black galaxy the second time
was when he helped him defeat Galactus
because who's going to be a bigger
villain for a world that devours then
the world devourer himself but too bad
he's a fantastic for character so no
Galactus and guardians of the galaxy
that would be a pretty epic fight but
let me know in the comments even though
we don't know how ego story is going to
end in the movie what do you want them
to do with him in the future if they can
do Living Planet weirdness in the MCU
then just think about the weird stuff
that they could do in the future so
what's going to happen next is is I have
a new flash episode that I'm going to
post and then I'll post the Guardians
trailer it's not posting till really
late tonight so my flash video just be
done before that so everybody get crazy
I'll be announcing the giveaway winner
when I post that is there any other
guardians videos that you guys want me
to do bonus videos for our characters or
concepts just let me know in the
comments where you wait to that click
here to watch that Guardians trailer and
you can click here for my flash episode
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys in the next
video